trouble
that's a great observation John Bella
said that you'd think it was stupid no I
said I thought it was stupid okay you
know what this is good right here I mean
the God of War Dynamic plays out in
every parent-child relationship when
that clicked for me I picked up my
Leviathan ax and fell truly close to my
son for the first time
I'm 17.
exactly Leviathan
ax Ronnie what's going on man you're a
little quiet today anything to add
no
no it's good no counts you know Quinn
was where you're at about a month ago
and uh look at him now
okay last night 2 am I'm laying in bed
what am I thinking about
Kratos are you kidding that's me big
time that's common for me we believe you
you're being too thirsty now I'm
hydrated specifically the time he tried
to protect atreus from balder Andres got
so angry he shot craters through the
chest with one of those um
like that spiky thingy it was an arrow
Arrow great spiky error thing I mean
nobody can hurt you like your kids right
[Music]
LeBron
queso
what's going on beneath that headband
I'm not even wearing one no I know you
know I mean like if you were when brawny
said he'd rather play against me than
with me
shot in the heart
really
I think we call that a breakthrough
some shots you just can't block
I could see that now Ben
Kratos I cannot believe I missed
practice for this I want all the
Breakthrough
Ella why don't you ever hurt my feelings
okay you're old and you're bald
just like Kratos
[Music]
now John last week you said you were
finally ready to wear your Kratos outfit
to the farmer's market how'd that go
incredible I had people pointing at me
going no that's a really great dad
that's not why they were pointing you
were wearing a Buckskin loincloth Ella
it's not block it's bear and I get those
points all the time people pointing oh
my God look at that great dad so why
aren't you wearing that stuff today
unfortunately my armor Bears the scars
of a recent battle
he spilled a bunch of salsa on it that
can happen especially with the Leathers
exactly look if it was easy every dad
would be dressed like this right does
the costume really help uh I don't know
does the costume really help when you
play basketball
it is a costume
PlayStation